hey how's it going for us money is
better path today we're playing John
Derry simulator the game that is about
loving someone yep that's it
Oh God every time ok so there's been a
long time since I play this game
I'm really excited because there's so
much that's been updated what gender is
your ideal nut lover of course I'm gonna
go with female uh what it went to male
so we can customize our semsem pipe hair
color yeah that that I'll do it how will
my true love look like two eyes bald the
[ __ ] is this let's go with that that's
it's pretty that's pretty [ __ ]
attractive right there let's get lights
glutes Jess oh we can really make a
mutiny oh I like this outfit it's pretty
cool I like how in Japan they have a
school outfits I know they have in other
countries too but I want to be a cowboy
schoolgirl what can I say man it's I
Holly recognize the game look at this
look at this computer and spirit manga
panties
of course there's panties oh God was it
these that's a run speed this is this is
the gossip panties this is the panties I
wear when I got sick awesome say our
prayers to the Lord and Savior Sampath
it's Richard
thank you thank you and let's go to
school okay a bunch of new stuff is that
senpai BAM
you're bald son of a [ __ ] goddamn you
look good you can send the picture and
that's how you get info this is probably
irrelevant let's say let's use Miko Chen
fairness she is a coward the [ __ ] is
going on like her tits are out of
control
they look like crab claws oh my god I've
learned more new info I can't believe
I'm doing this
she's a [ __ ] hey hey hey that's
oopsy-daisy looks like we got Simmons
Intel would be ashamed F an F a if it
came out to anyone
Oh oops sorry sorry type this really
funny joke I'm sorry for how I behaved
oh god we lost so much reputation for
laughing like a maniac the [ __ ] look at
that look at our panties oh okay what is
this we can buy drinks now awesome best
game best game best game awesome awesome
yes best game
oh we're so kawaai now look at this the
[ __ ] is this
nice nice wrappings yes BAM Shazam how
to lamb the [ __ ] is this best game ever
fabulous fabulous 50 people is haha why
is this a thing I can't
nice panty shot nailed it skims like
made for me I love it oh nice this is
how you crawl baby really great boob
physics I got a you gotta appreciate
that takes a lot of time and effort to
put that [ __ ] in there alright enough
enough [ __ ] around alright let's
let's do our objective here and that is
to [ __ ] with everyone so basically you
can KITT we kidnap people before but it
didn't have much effect so we are gonna
kidnap our victim or you can now torture
your victim and who doesn't want to do
that
someone get a phone call ooh ooh I don't
want to do that again ooh
whoo I can see her panties in Shih Tzu
to town oh oh she didn't see me
ha ha ha all right so another thing I
know we can do is to take a picture of
them there we go we get info on them she
has a crush on sampai she must die
oh god she looks so creepy in the night
how could we can go in the Internet this
is our Facebook I saw oka rock opera n
she suits attend
she was [ __ ] someone engaging in
compensated dating oh ah post it
everyone is confident about it they hate
her now I got it I'm a bully this is not
good
ah here we are choose stay just a
regular Tuesday are they playing Oh sue
Oh Oh she's sad and [ __ ] I'm just gonna
find a [ __ ] nursery hey I just want
to torture people is that too much to
ask they're in it oh my god
tranquilizer syringe boom but a pin but
a boom but a boom awesome dude awesome
where the [ __ ] is miku-chan where is she
ah hey bestie uh let's uh there is
something that I need help the [ __ ] is
this really embarrassing but I brought
school I can't find it anywhere
how do you how do you ask me what my bra
is missing sorry sorry sorry it's a long
story of course oh yeah yeah yeah
anytime a girl wants me to find her bra
I've never said no so far no one asked
actually at once it's a long story
don't ask oh my god I found it are you
kidding I didn't even get there oh my
god this is the best gaming
hi found your bra you found it thanks a
lot
best game ever all right now we're gonna
kidnap her follow me I'll show you
something cool my dick
now follow me god damn of your slow
maker Chan come on make a Chan come on
and got all day
there it is there it is hey how you
doing all right hey you like syringes
bit yeah
all right let's let's grab her she's
sleeping don't worry and let's dump her
I think we we go home right
so we travel back we sneak into the gym
and we uncover our victim let's say
let's go to basement is she still let oh
hey there hello there little child my
just my child how I am we taught you a
prisoner for one already real say let's
torture her 18 hours this game is
horrible
awesome waste we succeeded now we can
bring her to school
hahaha yes oh it's gonna be good guys
you can go to school so now I think I
think she can kill people for us ah here
we go yes yes hey how you doing that
make a [ __ ] you want some you want to
cut your hair you go have a sister oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] what's that what's that oh
[ __ ] don't kill [ __ ] by though can I
tell her to kill someone or she's just
gonna kill someone
oh oh oh oh oh oh
Oh Oh - hey oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] look at that [ __ ] she's
crazy
oh god what's she doing Oh No Oh
you
oh that's horrible that's terrible
whoops whoops I touched hey hey hey all
right all right that's enough
oh yeah and dairy similar for now let me
know if you want to play more of course
I'll play more I love this game think of
us watching leave a like it helps out a
lot
I'll see Bruce in the next one thank you
oh my god
you